zusammen und herzlich willkommen zu zdf
heute live an euren empfangsgeräten mit
einem stream über ein streitthema das
gerade sehr viele gemüter erhitzt es
geht um die sperrstunden anlässlich der
korona maßnahmen die sollten ja
eigentlich nach dem treffen im
kanzleramt am mittwoch einheitlich in
ganz deutschland seien aber derzeit
werden sie gerichtlich angegriffen und
fallen auch tatsächlich eine nach der
anderen
rechtlich sei das ganze so aus oder ist
vorgesehen dass bei 50 neuinfektionen
pro 100.000 einwohner innerhalb von
sieben tagen gastronomische betriebe um
23 uhr schließen müssen bis 6 uhr
morgens und bars und clubs müssen dann
ganz dicht machen und auch der
alkoholausschank ist dann bis 6 uhr
morgens verboten eigentlich muss man
sagen denn da gibt es viel durcheinander
es gibt gastronomen die dagegen klagen
manchmal kriegen sie recht manchmal
kriegen sie nicht recht über das
rechtliche spreche ich gleich mit meinem
kollegen felix zimmermann von der zdf
redaktion recht und justiz hier an
meiner seite und fragen zu der ganzen
thematik bitte sehr gerne wie immer in
die dafür vorgesehenen kommentarspalten
oder am hier unten zdf heute.de zdf.de
aber erstmal schalten wir dahin wo es
tatsächlich passiert der große streit um
die sperrstunde nennen mich nach berlin
zu meiner kollegin lisa jan de du stehst
mitten im corona hotspot besitzt an das
grab bei dir hallo mit einem chor oder
hotspot aber es sieht doch reichlich
harmlos aus denn hinter mir ist es
relativ leer wie ihr seht obwohl ihr
eigentlich viel los wir sind im
prenzlauer berg in der stargarder straße
aber es regnet es ist ungemütlich also
so viele leute treiben sich nicht rum
ich bin vor der bar marietta da sitzen
ein paar leute gemütlich drinnen und ein
paar auch draußen und hier ist einer der
barbesitzer die gegen diese schwere
stunde geklagt haben mit erfolg wie wir
jetzt wissen und deshalb gebe ich die
frage gleich mal an ihn weiter aus
welchem grund habt ihr denn gegen diese
sperrstunde geklagt
weil wir sie einfach als komplett
unfaires mittel empfinden letzten endes
den infektionsschutz durchzusetzen was
nur einfachen grund weil es nicht daten
und evidenzbasierte ist die sperrstunde
genau deswegen hat das gericht und sie
hat ja mehr oder minder auch erstmal
recht gegeben weil sie auch selber das
robert-koch-institut zitieren und sagen
dass laut robert koch institut die
gastronomie eine untergeordnete rolle
infektionsgeschehen spielt und das war
das war offensichtlich das wussten wir
halt auch schon offenbar nur der senat
von berlin wusste das nicht und hat
versucht wieder das übliche
durchzuziehen nämlich die gastronomie
und das nachtleben als übeltäter
schlechthin darzustellen und jetzt haben
wir es endlich amtlich schwarz auf weiß
nein so ist es nicht es ist wirklich
ziemlich kompliziert muss man sagen wenn
ich ein bisschen verwirrend
genau diese elf was die geklagt haben
dürfen jetzt wieder offen haben
und selbst das war wirklich krimi mäßig
heute noch denn berlin hat das nicht
hinnehmen wollen dass ihre ihr eilantrag
gegen die sperrstunde erfolg hat und hat
noch mal eine zwischenverfügung heißt
das beantragt so dass sie sogar hätten
heute doch noch schließen müssen also
ein echtes hin und her jetzt gerade kam
eben die nachricht nein das
oberverwaltungsgericht hat das abgelehnt
das heißt diese elf was die den
eilantrag gegen die sperrstunde
eingereicht haben dürfen
doch offen haben die beschwerde liegt
trotzdem noch vor aber das kann jetzt
noch wochen dauern bis das entschieden
wird
also jetzt erstmal ein erfolg nach einem
ganz schön aufregenden tag für dich oder
ja dass der tag war natürlich seitdem
dann heute um 11 uhr die meldung kam
dass die sperrstunde aufgehoben ist ein
einziges hin und her ein großes auf und
ab natürlich viele anfragen und ja die
freude war da und ist auch da
gleichzeitig ist gewissen es ist nur ein
kleiner teil aber wir reden ja davon
dass hier in berlin weiterhin ein
alkoholverkaufsverbot ab 23 uhr
stattfindet das heißt wir dürfen jetzt
zwar nach 23 uhr auf haben können aber
gleichzeitig kein alkohol mehr verkaufen
trotzdem ist es ein kleiner schritt ein
kleiner gefühlter sieg für uns auf jeden
fall und wir hoffen vor allen dingen das
in zwei wochen das
oberverwaltungsgericht auch weiterhin
der entscheidung des verwaltungsgerichts
von berlins folgen wird wir sehen nichts
was dagegen spricht
ja ich muss sagen auch das ist ja etwas
merkwürdig genau das alkoholausschank
verbot das besteht trotzdem das heißt
bis 22 59 kann man hier alkohol trinken
und dann eben nun auch wasser oder cola
dann noch mal die frage macht das
überhaupt sinn für euch wirtschaftlich
total also das macht auf jeden fall war
es macht auf jeden fall sind aus dem
einfachen grund jetzt mit der
sperrstunde war es ja so die leute
müssen ja um 11 uhr den laden verlassen
oder verlassen haben in dem sinne auf
gut deutsch die haben dementsprechend 22
uhr 22.15 der letztes getränk genommen
und jetzt wissen sie sie können hier
eben nach 23 uhr noch sitzen bleiben das
heißt sie kriegen um 23 uhr noch mal
erlebt das getränk hingestellt
das heißt wir haben einfach eine stunde
mehr geschäft es mag sich nicht viel
anhören aber eine stunde geschäft in der
haupt 2 22 uhr 23 uhr ist für die
gastronomie unglaublich wichtig also das
ist schon mal ein kleiner schritt ist
eine stunde mehr geld verdienen und
jetzt habe ich die basis in berlin noch
nicht und noch nie gezählt aber es sind
ja sehr viel mehr als 11 was ist mit den
anderen
das ist mit den anderen bars werden
hofft hier folgen oder wie wir das
ausgehen meinte wir hoffen jetzt dass
der senat dieses urteil heute von dem
verwaltungsgericht vielleicht nicht nur
liest um es juristisch zu prüfen sondern
es vielleicht auch einmal inhaltlich
nicht aber da würde ich dann auch die
sache kommt die gastronomie noch einmal
betone es spielt eine untergeordnete
rolle im infektionsgeschehen und zwar
aus dem einfachen grund weil sämtliche
bestellungen nicht sämtliche sagen
einmal wirklich der nahezu der großteil
der gastronomen ja eben hygienemaßnahmen
einfach umgesetzt hat und das macht sich
auch bemerkbar dadurch dass er jetzt
gerade nicht in die verantwortbarkeit
gezogen werden können weil die eben
diese untergeordnete rolle spielen und
deswegen
wenn der senat jetzt einmal richtig
liest wird es einfach an der zeit dass
er seine rät sei es also seine rhetorik
erinnert uns war einfach diese pranger
rhetorik mit der pranger politik gegen
die gastronomie muss beendet werden und
dieses urteil zeigt dass wir endlich als
verantwortungsbewusste mitspieler im
kampf gegen die pandemie wahrgenommen
werden sollten wir gastronomen sind
verantwortungsvolle mitspieler keine
gegner
das erwarte dafür sehen dass auch
langsam mal begreifen wieso da habe ich
ans rad weiter spannend ja ich höre was
gibt es in der frage ob ich würde ganz
gern mal das sehen wie das bei roberto
in der bar drinnen aussieht und auch
fast ein hygiene konzept ist wenn da
jetzt da sagte er ist ein
verantwortungsvoller mitspieler er will
auch sein partner in der ganzen sache
spielen die letzten besitzer innen drin
bei ihnen aber aus ich frage ihn einfach
mal und zwar die kollegen in mainz und
die zuschauer interessiert brennend wie
es in eurer in deiner bar aussieht und
wie dass sie jene konzepte zu sagen
aussieht vielleicht hat mir vorfeld ja
auch schon erklärt wie es jetzt im
vergleich zu vorher ist herr müller
reingehe
wir können gerne rein gehen natürlich
also ich hoffe es dass die gäste das
nicht weiter stört was ich auf jeden
fall schon mal sagen kann alleine das
hier ist neu haltezone außen tresen den
wir jetzt für den sommer die ganze zeit
hatten letzten endes um das geschäft
eben nicht drinnen zu verlagen sondern
es nach draußen eben zu machen und
gleichzeitig haben wir die plätze
natürlich maßgeblich reduziert
normalerweise gibt es doppelte viele
sitzplätzen wir jetzt hier drehen sehen
vielleicht wieder mit kurzen blick
reinwerfen
dann müssen wir uns aber auch in moskau
habe ich dabei natürlich so gehört wird
nämlich weil das ist tatsächlich einmal
tat ja keine maske dabei sobald man sich
im innenraum bewegt müssen wir halt auch
eben eine maske aufsetzen
an den tischen müssen die meisten gäste
keine maske aufzusetzen
das ist häufig nicht zu erklären
doch einfach mal rein dass du dich nicht
mehr interessieren wie folgt uns
sinnvoll dieser es ist eigentlich gut
besucht muss man sagen ja allerdings
sind normalerweise mehr zu schlagen
versucht trotzdem mal weiter zu
es war einfach nicht mehr platz das
normalerweise hier wo ich jetzt stehe
stehen auch gestern
das ist gerade nicht möglich machen
selbstbedienung hier nicht haben
normalerweise selbstbedienung ich an den
tresen gehabt jetzt bedienen wir nur
noch drin am tisch märz mit maske wir
machen die anwesenheits dokumentationen
wir haben die situation mittel das
vielleicht noch mal eine frage
unsere erfahrung ist dass die gäste
gerade also man muss zum beispiel auch
einfach sehen wir geben uns mühe der
versucht unser bestes hat eine
wohlfühlatmosphäre und eine sichere
atmosphäre zu erzeugen und das wird ein
wert geschäft und die gäste kommen dann
auch leben und vor allen dingen hatte
sich selber immer mehr und immer mehr
ganz von alleine an die regeln der
anfangszeit im sommer so viel ist noch
unklar weil da mussten wir die ständig
auf- oder sechs tore maske auf und
genau für einige setzt eure maske auf
bitte dass wir uns machen ihr abstand
halten
das was wird jetzt ganz allein das ist
auch das wichtige was ich glaube was die
politik begreifen
insgesamt die bevölkerung hat dazu
nicht mehr lösen regulatorische
fördermaßnahmen zu verlassen sondern
auch die disziplin zu ziehen
wir haben gelernt wie ersichtlich wer am
anfang der pandemie wir stecken jetzt
schon mittendrin
das ist aber selbst nein das war zu
erwarten
ok lisa nähe gerade nicht wir schalten
der gleich nochmal so herüber und sind
gespannt ob es dann auch voller ist in
der bar oder draußen zumindest da bin
ich mal gespannt wie ist dann im krieg
sieht jetzt würde ich gerne mit meinem
kollegen oder unseren kollegen felix
erstmal bei diese rechtlichen fragen
sprechen felix da sind auch schon hier
im stream kommen fragen auf
ich sag jetzt mal vielleicht erstmal für
dummies wie nicht so justiz nein
wie kommt es eigentlich dass so eine
maßnahme die am mittwoch quasi verkündet
wurde so schnell innerhalb von 48
stunden auf einmal umfeld wie so ein
stückchen im winter also die sperrstunde
in berlin war ich ein bisschen länger in
kraft aber prinzipiell hat jeder bürger
ein anspruch auf einstweiligen
rechtsschutz ja muss nicht immer ein
zwei jahre warten bis geschäftsbetrieb
pleite ist in dem fall sondern kann eine
sofortmaßnahme von einem gericht
verlangen
und das ist hier eben passiert mit der
eben vorgestellten folge dass man sagt
naja was bringt er so ein beherbergungs
verbot das auch aber das bringt auch nix
genau nach dem gericht aber das bringt
die sperrstunde 23 uhr wenn gar kein
alkoholausschank mehr stattfindet das
ist doch viel eher die gefahr dass die
leute dann nach hause gehen und privat
weiter trinken und da ist ja das
besondere infektionsrisiko also das war
die begründung von verwaltungsleiter wie
wie klappt das also wie funktioniert das
muss ich mir ein rechtsanwalt suchen
erst mal viel geld ausgeben oder kann
ich einfach ein brief aufsetzen und
schreiben liebe verwaltungsgericht
maßnahme doof unbegründet bitte kippen
es ist jetzt nicht so ganz einfach die
formellen voraussetzungen zu halten
grundsätzlich braucht man beim
verwaltungsgericht kein rechtsanwalt
also wenn man sich ein bisschen einließ
kann man es vielleicht auch so schaffen
und kriegt dann auch vielleicht von
gerichten hinweis
aber ich sag mal so ist schon besser in
solchen dingen rechtsanwalt zu
beauftragen
und das kann natürlich dann auch kosten
verursachen wenn man verliert
2500 euro in der ersten instanz wenn man
gewinnt trägt die gegenseite sämtliche
kosten ist das gedeckelt ist quasi so
eine flatrate ja das ist so also beim
verwaltungsgericht es gibt ja immer
diese streitwert ansetzung das umfeld
der regelstreit werden dass das dann
dabei rauskommt ok also ich kann einfach
dann einfach versuchen was bei rauskommt
wenn ich denke die 2500 euro ist mir das
wert
wenn ich verliere region haben wir jetzt
bedürftig ist und kein geld hat dann
gibt es die möglichkeit
prozesskostenhilfe zu beantragen und
dann kann man es umsonst machen
rechtsschutzversicherungen greift wieder
auch kann ich würde auch die ja die
würde gerade wenn ein geschäftsbetrieb
für solche anlässe eine
rechtsschutzversicherung hat würde ja
auch greifen so jetzt kommen wir fragen
für die ich von stefan kaiser auf
facebook was bringen all die
beschlossenen maßnahmen unserer
legislative wenn sie wieder von unserer
judikative außer kraft gesetzt werden na
gut wir sind im rechtsstaat und da muss
ich eben die exekutive im rahmen der
verfassung bewegen und einige gerichte
sagen das funktioniert hier nicht so
richtig also kurz die gesetz geben denn
das ist die gesetzgebung und sagt na ja
gut wir müssen wir gucken ob die regel
überhaupt sinn machen und plausibel sind
und weil ich eben ansprach des
werberings verbot da sagen eben auch
einige gerichte ja wieso ist denn im
bloßen reisen und beherbergen ein
besonderes infektionsrisiko im gegensatz
zu anderen dingen die erlaubt sind
reisen kann ja bedeuten sich ins auto
setzen ins ferienhaus fahren niemand da
die regeln sind zu pauschal einigen
gericht hat aber andere sorgen auch und
nachher gut jede person aus einem krone
hotspot ist ein risiko für andere wir
halten die beherbergungs mutter aufrecht
und prinzipiell um die fragen um mal
konkret zu beantworten
natürlich ist es so dass die gerichte
wenn die politik sinnvolle plausible
maßnahmen nach die auch halten ja das
hat man ja gelebt und die geben die nach
gewissen spielraum der politik aber muss
eben genau die grundrechte beachten das
passiert eben manchmal nicht so richtig
das ganze betrifft ja uns
deutschlandweit weil es ja einheitlich
sein soll das führt jetzt was zu dass es
schon in mehreren deutschen städten
diese sperrstunden gibt wir haben da mal
eine karte vorbereitet auf denen wir die
uns genauer angucken können und zwar ist
das jetzt derzeit in berlin der fall da
ist aber teilweise gekippt heute abend
haben wir gerade gehört in hamburg von
23 bis 5 uhr ab morgen gilt das ganze in
münchen gibt es bislang keine obwohl sie
kommen könnte
in köln haben wir jetzt noch drauf
stehen 1 bis 6 uhr die haben das auch
gerade geändert die karte konnten wir
nicht mehr ändern ab morgen soll sie
gelten ab 23 uhr
und genauso in frankfurt 23 bis 6 uhr
das heißt wer jetzt feiern gehen möchte
diesen städten kann das teilweise heute
noch machen teilweise eben auch nicht in
berlin eben nur in diesen elf kneipen in
diesen gastronomischen betrieben die
geklagt haben
felix da ist jetzt die frage du hast
gerade gesagt die gerichte halten das ja
eigentlich denn die maßnahmen begründet
erscheinen jetzt kippt das beherbergungs
verbot in vielen bundesländern wird die
sperrstunde erfolgreich angegriffen
hätte dass die bundesregierung und die
landesregierungen nicht vorher wissen
können dass das irgendwie recht wackelig
ist und dann hätten sie sich diese acht
stunden sparen können am mittwoch
normalerweise sind diese ganzen
grundrechts intensiven sachen die
wirklich freizügigkeit
versammlungsfreiheit berufsfreiheit
einschränken
das findet ja normalerweise im parlament
statt ein gesetz verabschiedet wird
und jetzt in diesen krisenzeiten ist
eben die stunde der exekutive und das
heißt auch dass sie vorschnell manchmal
schnell mal reagieren muss sie muss
schnell reagieren aber da passieren eben
auch mehr fehler wird eben nicht alles
vielleicht so durchgeprüft man muss
natürlich auch mal wieder sagen also
manche gerichte halten das ja auch für
zulässig also es ist ja nicht ein
pauschales urteil getroffen so dass wir
jetzt die situation haben dass wir
zuerst gesagt haben da diese ganzen
politiker wollen können sie sich nicht
einigen
naja dann einigen sie sich und jetzt
machen aber die gerichte da nicht mit
und manche sagen im beherbergungs verbot
ist zulässig manche sagen es ist
rechtswidrig
also haben wir diesen flickenteppich
jetzt quasi auf juristischer ebene von
seiten der gerichte ist er steckt an
juristen herz daher dass man sagt klima
der rechtsstaat funktioniert oder ist
wüsste da er verärgert dass das doch
jetzt wieder so durcheinander geht so
als persönliche einschätzung
ich bin wir mal so zufrieden darüber
dass man sieht wir haben gerichte die
lassen dem staat nicht alles durchgehend
rechtsstaat funktioniert jetzt mal ganz
unabhängig davon ob ich die urteile gute
fall stelle finde ich es eine
beglückende ja feststellung dass das
funktioniert das ist eine gute sache
dass also die regierungen nicht einfach
machen können was sie für richtig halten
ich habe mir mal ein paar kommentare die
eure meinung so widerspiegeln zb
advocatus diaboli auf youtube schöner
name schreibt die berliner richter haben
echten offen absteht glaube ich für
apfelsaft läppische verschärfungen man
irgendwelche fahrlässigen gericht zu
kippen selbst die noch so wird der
zweite doktoren auf jeden fall kommen
also hier quasi unzufriedenheit mit dem
rechtsspruch kann man auch so sehen ja
was ganz interessant ist viele gerichte
begründen gerade die entscheidung damit
dass andere sachen ja nicht verboten
sind also fragen warum wurde jetzt
gerade die beherbergung verboten warum
wurde gerade die sperrstunde gemacht
denn eine person die aus einem anderen
hotspot kommt die kann ja zum beispiel
einkaufen gehen in nur anderen
bundesland warum soll ich gerade die
beherbergung verboten sein
das heißt wenn es jetzt maßnahmen
getroffen würden die vielleicht sogar
intensiver werden aber für alle gleich
gelten würden dann hätten die gerichte
dieses argument nach dem motto warum ist
das eine verbotene das andere nicht
nicht mehr
ja und prinzipiell muss man wohl auch
den user noch mal darauf hinweisen wir
haben eben nicht gesundheitsschutz als
super grundrecht dass alle anderen
schlägt das ist nicht so sondern wir
brauchen und berufsfreiheit
freizügigkeit versammlungsfreiheit auch
aber dass grundrechte und sie dürfen
eben nicht eingeschränkt werden ohne
sinn und verstand zugunsten nur des
gesundheitsschutzes jetzt gibt es hier
gerade kritik an meinem kommentar zum
feiern gehen von wilfried schumacher auf
facebook schreibt der jetzt feiern gehen
möchte sondern es heute abend auch
lassen auch ohne sperrstunde der
moderator hat wohl den schuss nicht
gehört also ich das war zugegeben ein
bisschen flapsiger kommentar ich meinte
aber damit vor allem auch die tatsache
dass ist ja ein bisschen absurd ist
hätte ich vielleicht ein bisschen
ausformulieren sollen dass man heute
jetzt noch weggehen kann und ab morgen
dann nicht mehr hier wird auch angemerkt
die so 23 uhr der virus das virus hört
ja nicht auf und 23 uhr zu führten also
sprich heute abend könnte man sich noch
fleißig anstecken und morgen dann nicht
mehr also diese diese willkürlichkeit
wert wird hier auch öfter mal ich für
eine feiern feiern natürlich soll man
feiern es geht nicht ums feiern sondern
es geht darum wie man feiert ja man kann
jetzt auch nicht einen ganzen jungen
generation für keine ahnung noch bis
sommer oder wie lange es dauert das
feiern verbieten also das geht nicht und
deswegen ist die frage wie man feiert
na ja das kann man ja auch vernünftig
gestalten und deswegen finde ich das
nicht falsch zu sagen
doch feiern gehen sondern dann ist gilt
ja auch gerade die sie gesehen haben das
alkoholverbot das heißt großmengen ist
dann nicht mehr angesagt sondern es geht
dann wohl gesittet dazu wie man
erfahrungsgemäß hoffen wir zumindest er
also das ist hier ist auch ein einkommen
taten nicht tatsächlich bekommen habe so
dass es natürlich die die hemmungen
fallen mit dem alkohol
hier gibt es noch andere kommentare von
carpe diem auf youtube gastronomie ist
nicht gleich gastronomie bedauerlich
dass kein unterschied zwischen einer bar
mit acht sammeln menschen und einer mit
vollidioten gemacht werden kann alle
leiden darunter wegen wenigen das ist
auch ein tenor denen man aus der
gastronomie von vielen hört das gibt es
ja noch mal gerne ganz generell die
frage von kersten wiggenhorn gibt es
eigentlich auch noch andere nachrichten
aus la corona oder hofer soll abgelenkt
werden liebe frau wiggenhorn wir möchten
von gar nichts ablenken wir wollen einen
fokus linken auf eine frage die gerade
sehr viele menschen umtreibt und auch
fragezeichen hinterlässt nämlich wie
kann es eigentlich sein dass diese
sperrstunde erst erlassen wird dann
wieder kippt teilweise doch nicht kippt
das stift bei vielen menschen mit denen
wir gesprochen haben laufe des tages
doch fragezeichen auf so ich schaue
jetzt noch mal ob es irgendeine frage
gibt die zu beantworten kannst felix ich
hatte ja noch mal eine gefunden ich muss
noch mal kurz suchen genau david möchte
thissen auf facebook warum haben die
länder in diesen fragen so viele
kompetenzen warum wird bei so einer
internationalen krise nicht mehr auf
bundesebene entschieden also warum ist
diese pandemie bekämpfung ländersache
genau das ist hier so bei uns eine
verfassung geregelt eigentlich der
grundsatz ist die länder haben die
kompetenzen
es sei denn es ist im grundgesetz
geregelt dass der bund sie hat und es
gibt eben keine bundeskompetenz für
gesundheitsfragen deswegen es ist auf
der seiten der länder das ist jetzt
natürlich kann man da teilweise als
unsinnig einstufen hat sich aber auch
vielleicht erwiesen
das ist durchaus sinn machen kann dass
man eben für verschiedene staaten
unterschiedlich bundesstaaten
unterschiedlich reagiert je nachdem wie
das infektionsgeschehen sich entwickelt
und es hat ja auch teilweise vielleicht
den vorteil dass der eine das konzept
probiert der andere das und dann sieht
man war ja da der region das ist aber
jetzt nicht gut gelaufen
man weiß ja man hat ja schwierigkeiten
in die zukunft zu sehen und in dieser
situation zu gucken was ist richtig
man kann es natürlich auch so ich
jedenfalls die idee des
verfassungsgebers da
zu unterschiedlichen wettbewerben der
regelungen kommen und sagte das ist der
gute weg den wir jetzt weiter war bei
vielen gibt es dann den eindruck es ist
ein hin und her die politik ist sich
nicht einig es gibt keine klare linie
ist das vielleicht eine falsche
wahrnehmung könnte man auch vielleicht
eher sagen ihr super dass es
verschiedene konzepte gibt ja es ist
natürlich einfach für den verbraucher
und für die gewerbetreibenden höchst
schwierig und da den überblick zu
bewahren
das ist wohl das entscheidende problem
mein letztes nur der agentur ausgedruckt
das ist ja immer alles sehr kompakt
zusammengefasst mit den verschiedenen
regelungen in allen bundesländern als
fan elf seiten
das muss man auch erstmal checken genau
deswegen ist natürlich schon zu wünschen
dass sich die politik quasi
zusammensetzt und die kann ja trotzdem
noch unterschiedliche regeln machen pro
gebiet das haben wir jetzt auch gemacht
an sich nur 35 50 je nachdem wie die
lizenz ist aber die kanzlerin die kann
natürlich die ministerpräsidenten an den
tisch bitten um sich zu einigen was ich
aber nicht machen kann ist die gerichte
einen tisch bitten weil diesen
unabhängig und da gibt es keinen
einfluss das haben wir heute wieder
gesehen und das ist auch gut so felix
vielen dank für diese rechtlichen und
justiz rechtlichen und
verfassungsrechtlichen einschätzungen
mal wieder von dir und ich schalte das
noch mal zu dieser über die weiterhin in
berlin steht in einem der hotspot
gebiete vor der bar die einer der bars
wo der inhaber geklagt hat und gesagt
hat das geht so nicht ich möchte dass
diese sperrstunde gekippt wird der darf
auch weiter offenhalten hast du mal mit
ein paar gästen gesprochen wie finden
sie das
ja also ich habe hier ganz viel rufen
gesprochen und die finden das alle
natürlich gut dass er offenheit offen
bleiben darf und vor allen dingen hoffen
sie dass die anderen berliner bars auch
bald wieder offen bleiben dürfen aber
man soll nicht über sondern mit den
menschen reden deshalb wir fragen
einfach mal die gäste zwei sitzen
nämlich hier die habe ich schon mal
vorher gefragt hey und michael
genau ich frage euch jetzt einfach mal
direkt das interessiert natürlich alle
die ihr als erste der war das so findet
mit dieser schwer stunde und dass ich
natürlich jetzt gekippt wurde
ja so war das gekippt wurde würde ich
sagen
weil also ich arbeite sehr viel im
home-office der zeit und es fehlt mir
einfach supertoll menschen um mich herum
zu haben
das hat er nicht zwangsläufig etwas mit
alkohol zu tun sondern einfach hier sein
zu können und in der gesellschaft sein
finde ich super das ist diese
sperrstunde überhaupt gab
hat euch dass ihr habt ihr es gefunden
hat das aus ihrer sicht sinn macht so
richtig sinn macht es nicht weil in den
großen
solche themen wie zum beispiel im
fußball gibt es ja auch entsprechende
hygiene konzepte die eingehalten werden
die gibt es ja auch sicher leben den
bars und von daher finde ich dass man da
mit zweierlei maß misst und das
überhaupt nicht gut ankommt dieser wie
ist das überhaupt generell in version
die nächste das war oder wir denen das
auch seine beiden gäste war wird sich
daran gehalten also wird es das bringen
wenn man jetzt die paz zu macht oder
rennen die leute dann einfach auf den
nächsten plätzen den nächsten park und
rotten sich hat da zusammen und machen
halt da party weiter ohne dass sie die
manchmal darauf kopie ein bild zusammen
spielen
genau das ist natürlich die befürchtung
das ist auch das was ganz viele erstens
barbesitzer uns erzählt haben aber es
hat auch was die leute selbst erzählt
haben junge leute beispielsweise am
rosenthaler platz oder woanders
die letzte woche uns schon gesagt wir
gehen jetzt natürlich nicht nach hause
um 11 als die sperrstunde eben erstmals
wirkte und die meisten aufnahmen und
zweiten sechser und gehen nach hause
also das hat die abendplanung nicht
wirklich einschneidend verändert und
viele barbesitzer haben ja das hat auch
gesagt na ja wir konnten ja immerhin
noch sagen hallo maske auf halo bisschen
abstand halten ist richtig tanzen und
dass das eben dann völlig unter außer
kontrolle geraten kann
aber ich kann die frage immer weiter
gehabt wie ist ihr eindruck
bringt das was im sinne von würden die
leute sich auch daran halten oder die
feiern wollen feiern hat trotzdem offen
die basta also ich glaube die die feiern
wollen feiern immer also wir merken es
ja auch bei uns zu einer straße das hat
enorm zugenommen mit lauter musik
größere gruppen unterwegs sind
ich glaube nicht dass das unbedingt
verhindert und ich denke auch dass er
mal zuviel verbietet dass das dann genau
das dann so ein bisschen die kontrolle
und der hinweis da irgendwie verloren
geht
ich habe mir eine frage die so machen
sich auch ähnlich michael sorry michael
und meinen auf die frage an dich
die brigitte mehr wissen warum ist sie
im home office arbeitet und dann in eine
bar zu gehen könnt ihr sogar ich fast
beantworten ohne die liebe zu kennen
aber in warum arbeit im home-office um
dann in eine bar zu gehen
na ja also ich arbeite ja nicht ganz
freiwillig im home-office wir haben
natürlich strenger regelungen
es dürfen nur also bei mir jetzt auf der
etage ab leute seien es ist heiß begehrt
wir haben eine liste wo man sich
eintragen muss und wenn man nicht früh
genug dran das tanken kommt man halt
nicht mehr ins büro rein so und ja dann
gehe ich aus ja und so weit wie ich das
verstanden habt gebt ihr auch zusammen
oder lebt das heißt sie sind dabei aber
ich kann das bezeugen sie war ganz
anständig und hat sich dann alles
gehalten gibt es ja mit ihrem
lebenspartner hier also ich glaube die
immer kommt ja auch schwer darauf an wie
man etwas macht na also und die beiden
jetzt irgendwie ein rotwein am abend
zusammen ihr seid jetzt nicht die
totalen absoluten ihren feier leute die
jetzt noch in hasenheide einen drauf
machen oder die festival premiere ich
gesagt am main jetzt kommt raus
ja es ist schon so also festivals und
konzerte traurig dass sie gerade nicht
mehr stattfinden
ja ja die gab es gab noch gestört hat
also in deine richtung doch keine maske
trägt und müssen wir uns sorgen wie es
draußen muss mir also ich bin draußen
wir müssen keine maske draußen trage ich
gebe es nicht hat wohin darüber
nachgedacht einfach nur so aus respekt
allerdings halten wir hier gut abstand
und wir sind draußen
ich hoffe also ich hab dann gedacht dass
sie so in ordnung und wir haben in
berlin zu geben auch keine masken
pflicht draußen natürlich heißt dass man
sich machen kann wenn man aber aber
solange opfern dass er sich vor allem am
stand genau dafür genau darauf achten
wir natürlich viel besser war übrigens
auch nicht mit der keule sondern ja
vorher ja mit mit der mangelnde kann man
gratis
vielleicht kannst nur mal kurz zeigen
wir vermacht aus dem abstand gehen man
die angel zeigen wie du dann eher im den
ton an als weil genau sonst hätte ich
normalerweise würde ich mich darüber
beugen
für jetzigen verhältnisse viel zu nah
ran und das machen wir jetzt natürlich
nicht sondern mit es macht der kollege
mit dem ganzen also der kollegin von der
arbeitssicherheit im zdf ist mit
sicherheit zufrieden mit dir
vielen dank nach berlin für die
einschätzungen und eindrücke und ich
gucke mal habe ich einen kommentar
findet den ich irgendwie beantworten
kann oder
wir beantworten können aber ich glaube
fast wir haben alles bis jetzt
durchgeackert es ist ein schwieriges
thema es ist ein thema an dem sich die
geister scheiden das wird auch weiterhin
so bleiben so blöd sie mit der
sperrstunde schreibt tom auf facebook
und ich schliesse mal einfach mit dem
kommentar hier von marco mallorca
naujokat auf youtube an dieser stelle an
der er mal ein kleines dankeschön
bisschen im großen strom vielen dank
dafür mag das freut uns den machen jetzt
erstmal wochenende sehen uns nächste
woche wieder in den livestreams und in
den gewohnten zdf-sendungen ich freue
mich wenn ihr dabei seid doch erstmal
danke heute fürs zugucken für eure
kommentare und bis zum nächsten mal
machs gut und tschüss